spotted hyenas are crafty killers here
on this Serengeti Plain especially when
they're hungry and right now they're
very hungry they have a reputation as
scavengers but as we can see they can
hunt and bring down prey far bigger than
themselves by using the strategy of the
pack first they separate the mother
Buffalo and her calf from the herd the
cape buffalo is a large aggressive
animal so the hyenas are taking a big
risk
but once they're on the attack
the spotted hyenas are relentless they
separate the mother from the calf and
bring down the calf the mother watches
this but knows there's nothing she can
do she saves herself and rejoins the
herd once the feast is on dedicated
scavengers like this lappet-faced
vulture try to join the party
but the famished hyenas aren't in a mood
to share about all that are left are
tiny scraps out here nothing goes to
waste the scraps are carried off by ants
this hyena wants to indulge in another
favorite pastime the dust bath but it's
chosen a location a little too nearer
mother Jacqueline or pups
[Music]
the hyena doesn't seem to be as
interested in the pups as the pups are
in the hyena in fact it appears the
voracious hyena has no interest in
making a meal out of it which allows the
pups to get on with their meal
[Music]